[Music]
the education system in america still
reeling from the massive damage done by
liberal coveted lockdowns kids falling
behind both academically and mentally
and now there's nobody around to even
teach them schools across the country
are dealing with a massive teacher
shortage and biden's secretary of
education threatens it could even get
worse
we're at the doorstep of a crisis in our
country if we don't take it seriously
we're going to have schools closing and
we don't need that nick instead of
dealing with that pressing problem
school administrators are more focused
on woke academics for instance right now
a virginia education proposal is seeking
to strike george washington as quote
father of the u.s but don't worry
teachers unions are blaming republicans
for the staffing crisis top union boss
randy weingarten who is instrumental in
keeping kids in isolation is blaming the
shortage on republicans who she says
politicized public education
okay so
greg yes
randy weingarten says it's all the
republicans fault this crisis that
cardona says we're in the middle of is
because of republicans what could she be
talking about well they're right about
george washington he's a cis-normative
male uh
and uh we have to change that these
these binaries are destroying america
what's interesting here is that we've
we've done stories where children
children are literally missing from
their schools now like a million two
million three million and now we have a
shortage of teachers
so if you have a shortage of students
and a shortage of teachers what does
that tell you about the system that the
system sucks and who is responsible for
the system sucking something called the
teachers union which prohibits
competition with their system because
that's the only way the rot can be
maintained which is which is why what's
happening in arizona is so amazing i
think that it was governor ducey is that
how you say it
our very own governor ducey
signed a bill in which parents can fund
students and not systems so that allows
for choice and competition and it's an
experiment and if they do it well then
other states are going to follow suit
and you're going to see a huge change
and you got a shout out to that corey
deangelis kid because he's the guy
that's really behind this movement yeah
every parent should follow follow up
what corey deangelis is doing because
it's the parents that are pushing this
and this could really really change
things because the the the problem with
america is rooted in its education
system we keep talking about college no
by the time people are 18 their lives
are already ruined by public school yeah
we got to get them before that
well what about dana the fact that
they're not admitting it's their doing
the fact that kids have been out of
school for a year and a half some of
them two years because they said they
didn't have the proper equipment to go
in and teach and even now they're saying
they want kids masked this is a huge
problem and when cardona said that we
have there's a crisis upon us yes it's
like okay well you've been in power for
nearly two years and all of a sudden you
think there's a crisis it's like the
baby formula thing they knew about that
for months but they didn't even tell the
president about it and that's still a
problem that's going on and you also
have a shortage of what else police
detectives corrections officers why
would that be well it's not just the pay
it's not because you go into public
service as a teacher or a police officer
or go into corrections because you
really want the high pay
usually if you're going into those jobs
it's because you want to be a part of
society you want to be a part of raising
children you want to be part of the
education system teachers love teaching
but what had happened they had to go
zoom school
they watched these kids that either
don't either they either don't come back
or they had so much learning loss that
they couldn't possibly keep up and
they're getting judged by that the
parents aren't being responsible 96 of
the money that american taxpayers gave
for schools during covet has not been
spent
and the financial incentives are not
going to do it the policies have to
change a lot of this wokeness is also
driving them out the fact sean that that
that dana talks about the fact that that
covert money isn't being spent and now
teachers are saying look we're not being
paid enough
uh is there any way to resolve this in
terms of where is that covered money
will someone tell me where it is who's
using it who has the right to use it
well first of all the administration's
coming out and saying we need to pay
teachers more and by the way teachers
gave 20 million dollars to democrats and
and joe biden in the 2020 campaign so
this is this is a payback for teachers i
listen i don't mind paying the good
teachers more but they're saying listen
teachers make twenty percent less than
people with similar degrees but they
also work twenty percent unless they
have school their summer's off
we should pay we should pay good
teachers more the problem is they won't
allow us to look at the performance of
the teacher our kids learn how to read
and write and do math and if they are
let's pay them but if you're teaching
them to be woke
we shouldn't pay them more by the way
you're going to get more teachers if you
stop attacking people of faith you stop
promoting racism and you stop hating
america you might go hey i'll go teach
there but if you do that those things
you won't get folks in the minneapolis
well you know one of the things that's
just that the white teachers get fired
first yeah yeah but what let's talk
about the fact that if there's a
shortage of teachers people like ron
desantis are saying you know maybe we
can replace them with ex-police officers
access to that i and i know what you're
going to say they have to be confident
but
you know at the same time i'm not sure i
wouldn't rather have a cop teaching a
kid than someone saying you know your
whole country is racist and the color of
your skin decides whether you're a
racist
i don't know of a teacher who did say
those things to the points about you
know bringing people who've been in
other fields back to teaching if they
pass the exams and they're qualified to
teach whatever the subject level is i
would welcome it
you want the best people possible and
the people who want to be in those
classrooms there and available to our
kids the money's a huge piece of that
you know everyone is campaigning on
paying teachers more you could take
money out of the american rescue act to
do that um part of what's going on
though in cities like here in new york i
was out with a couple last night who
just moved to connecticut because their
child they live in brooklyn went into
the lottery system she got the 11 her
11th of 12th choice and there are kids
who live across the street from a school
and did not get zoned in for it so what
did they do they moved to a state where
there are great public schools and
they're in the catchment zone and they
know that their children will be going
to that school parents need security to
know especially when you're making a
real estate investment which is one of
the top reasons that families move right
for that great school that your kid is
guaranteed a spot in that school no
matter what goes on home school
it's i mean it's rising in popularity or
making pods i think is a great approach
find you know 10 like-minded families
exactly pay a teacher 200 000
and have a homeschool pod
there's a lot they can do but i still
want to know where's the money up next
is the squad secretly getting rich off
the socialist policies they keep pushing
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now